hi there Steve Kaufman here today I want
to talk about how we can make progress
or progress how do we progress in
language learning and to me the answer
is very simple
keep moving move forward that's what
progress means move forward advance let
me explain what I mean
we often get at link learners who come
on
and they tell me that they've been
listening to the same lesson 30 40 50
times and they've been doing this over a
period of months and they're trying very
hard you know to make sure that they
learn the lesson but there's still parts
of it that they don't understand and and
parts of it that they keep forgetting
and so forth and what should they do
well my answer is move on to something
else don't stay at one lesson and listen
to it 30 or 40 times you have to admit
you want to advance advance move forward
when I start in a language yes I will
listen to very simple content you know
less than a minute long 30 seconds long
and I listen to it 10 20 times maybe not
all at once like a lot of our beginner
lessons that link are part of a series
so there might be 20 of them so I might
listen to one of them twice for three or
four times then do the second one and
the third one and the fourth one always
listening to three four or five times
then go back to the first one again the
immediate challenge in a language is to
even pick out where you know one word
ends and the next word begins it's all
sort of indiscriminate noise at first
but as you progress and as you can at
least tell where the words begin or
previous word ends then you are now
ready to start moving a little more
quickly in my opinion and I say in my
opinion because you know we all have to
decide how we want to learn I can only
share with you
what works for me and what I think is
good and if I think it's good for me I'm
inclined to think it's good for other
people but there are lots of polyglots
who are very successful and who have
different methods and you should listen
to them all and find those things that
they have in common or those things that
work for you but I only talk about what
works for me and what I think is good
and I think it's good to listen a lot at
the beginning maybe for a month but not
twenty times on one lesson maybe have a
simple series of lessons which could be
from a beginner series like teach
yourself it doesn't have to be our
program at link and listen two three
four times to lesson one and then move
on to lesson two and do the same and
three and so forth you can always go
back you should go back you know I think
we have this idea in school that we kind
of go from lesson one to two to three
and if we don't lesson learn it while
we're on lesson one will never learn it
that's just not true you have to keep on
going back and in fact it's very
difficult to learn it while you're on
that lesson it's difficult to learn
anything no matter how hard you try like
you know as an example so many times you
know I'll think of a word in Russian
that I've heard many times and I'll say
I'll go and look it up now because I
really want to know what that word means
and I'll do that and I'll look it up but
I'll forget it again how many times have
I looked at the you know the declension
tables because I'm still struggling with
whatever and I go and look it up and oh
yeah okay now I know you know not a day
or two later I've already forgotten it
because you just need so much exposure
before these things start to become
natural for you so it's very important
not to stay with one lesson and one book
that I often mention which is how the
brain learns I think it's called
learning something do with the brain but
the writer of this book is a neuro
scientist called Manfred Spitzer from
Germany and there are two quotes that I
often use the first one was that
the brain in order to learn requires
repetition but it also requires novelty
once there's no more novelty the brain
stops learning it needs new things so it
needs basically a mixture of repetition
and novelty if you're staying with one
lesson and trying to force these things
into your brain the novelty aspect is
now gone diminishing returns the law of
diminishing returns sets in you're
learning less and less you can't force
yourself in that way
therefore it's far better to move along
progress advance move forward onto
something else because those words that
you're trying to learn if they're
important they will come up again
meanwhile you're stimulating your brain
hopefully with interesting content it's
something new and fresh the brain is now
turned on again to try to learn
something and everything it's so normal
to forget normal not to understand you
don't have to wait until you understand
you know a hundred percent of the lesson
I'll move on when I understand fifty
sixty percent but I always go back and
it's very nice when you go back and then
you understand more and and I think it's
also a good idea to very sort of more
challenging material often authentic
material with easy material so if you're
driven by an interest in political
events or history or literature or
whatever music to push yourself push the
barriers to go to more and more
difficult material you should
occasionally go back and do easier
material because when you look at
beginner material where you know all the
words you're able to focus on those
structures or problems that you have so
it's often a good idea to give yourself
a break every now and again and go back
and do easier material that was one of
the quotes from Manfred Spitzer we need
repetition and we need novelty new
things another quote was learning takes
place in the brain not in the classroom
and that's very important because a lot
of our traditional views about how we
learn are conditioned by our experience
in the classroom we have to have lesson
1 and then lesson 2 and that's lesson 3
learn it we're gonna learn for the test
and then we'll have it and of course it
doesn't work that way
countless generations of kids have gone
through school passing their tests and
French let's say English school system
in Canada and they graduate and they
can't speak so that the whole process of
learning all this stuff cramming it for
the exam may enable you to pass the exam
it doesn't enable you to learn the
language and if we look around the world
most people learn languages outside the
classroom those countries in Europe
where television programs and movies are
in the original language they are better
at foreign languages as a general rule
than those countries where they don't do
that if you go to Sweden or Holland they
all watch TV in English but there's no
less than one in the TV the kid starts
watching a cartoon series or whatever it
might be he's hit with the language and
that's gradually how his familiarity
with the language improves so of course
when you're learning you can be a little
more purposeful than that because you
can listen to things that you can also
read as in our lessons that link you can
look up words you can study the words
but don't stay too long on the same
material
keep moving yourself forward let's see I
had some notes here yeah the thing about
language too is unlike other skills you
know engineering medicine music these
are things that in a way we have to
learn a little more deliberately
although my wife and and my
granddaughter have progressed much more
in piano playing since they stopped
having to sit down with a teacher once a
week in other words they're motivated to
learn on their own they play and they
learn but still the thing about language
that makes it different is that language
surrounds us we can get this access to
language everywhere we can find movies
we can find radio we can find podcasts
that language surrounds us so it's not
quite the same as learning a specific
technique and and even they're like
credentials which comes up quite
regularly I think cred
initials in terms of a credential you
know a teaching credential and so forth
is quite irrelevant to language learning
or even language teaching there is no
correlation between the credentials of
the teacher and the teachers success
what matters is the teachers experience
ability to communicate to convey
enthusiasm not necessarily experience
but knowledge of the subject enthusiasm
can ability to encourage and so forth so
the credentials which govern you know
how to organize a class and some of the
things that are taught there it's not
bad but it doesn't necessarily determine
who is in a position to help you learn
because the learning is not just done in
a classroom so when you go out to try to
you know determine how you should go
about learning a language by all means
listen to what teachers have to say but
also check in on some of the other
people on the Internet and there are
thousands of them who are handing out
advice on how to learn language under no
means the only one but my advice for
today is if you want to move forward if
you want to progress in your language
keep moving forward don't get stuck
don't try to nail things down it's too
difficult to do eventually through this
exposure to more and more interesting
material to a mixture of repetition and
novelty the brain will start to acquire
the language so there you have it on how
to progress in language learning thank
you for listening bye for now